these guys say it
hi everybody hi Brian it's so nice to
meet you guys we have three experiments
we want to show you and the first
experiment that we have is that baking
soda and vinegar experiment so whenever
you put the baking soda in the vinegar
it creates a chemical reaction that
looks like it explodes well what's
really happening is that sense form is
an acid and one is a bit ace it creates
carbon dioxide that is trying to escape
alright still watch watch watch just
gonna do it we need to do that okay the
next experiment that we have is the
lava-lamp experiment all you need is
water with some food coloring and some
vegetable oil and remember you mix the
vegetable wheel with the water it
doesn't mix you can crush shake it you
know why that's because they have
different density the vegetable oil is
less dense than water so it floats on
top and next Unni can pop the saucer
when I really put the alka-seltzer
inside anymore it creates a bunch of
bubbles which is carbon dioxide trying
to escape you guys see it a little bit
closer inside that's so cool can see why
awesome gotta try that we're gonna do
this with you
all right so yeah okay synchroflow
what is it is it about a bouncy ball
ping pong ball a ping pong ball pair
ping pong balls not as heavy as a bouncy
ball what do you think you think the
ping pong ball is gonna flow in a flow
all right what do you have next this one
is gonna sink or float that looks pretty
heavy
eventually let's see 3 2 1 go it flows
and my favorite pocket oh no I did not
think an apple was gonna fly I thought
the Apple would sink what why do you
think I know it was the piston 8x8 maybe
maybe all the products is really good
two things it has a kid inside well then
we did science for today we're good a
cherry tomato a cherry tomato a little
tiny tomato and that's all the
experiments we have planned I hope you
guys enjoyed it awesome thank you guys
like I said you covered our science to
the day I'm great I'm done
[Music]